nev campbell in studio honor number
three i just categorized the horror
movie that ruined the genre for me and i
said it was rudy
so
you know
honestly
i was horrified by it and that thus
makes it a horror movie question why did
you have to bring that into his albert
didn't go to notre dame oh i had nothing
to do with albert prayer you know what i
mean that's nothing to do with albert
brewer i don't know if i we're where
albert stands on all this our friend of
sports illustrated right here on the
rich eyes each other the man who pens
the mmqb every day how are you albert we
have a lot to dig into there i was a big
fan of evan nev campbell when i was a uh
when i was a teenager i uh i i said you
can tell her i especially enjoyed her
working wild things i think people my
age would remember that one okay
so how do you how do you classify rudy
is rudy a sports movie or a horror movie
for you uh uh
you see i never liked notre dame as you
know rich um i actually grew up a
michigan fan because my my dad my
grandfather and everything else so i
didn't like them then
and then you know going to ohio state
things don't really change in that
regard they're sort of
i don't know like nose in the air we're
too good for the big ten like i never
liked that about them so
i mean i watched rudy um
because i was i mean i think i went to
it if i remember i went to it was like
my pop warner team you know middle
school okay um so i think it's a good
movie um i don't think it's a horror
movie like i think it's
but but i but i have heard that it's
embellished a little bit right like
maybe rudy's not the feel-good guy feel
good character that uh the people make
him out to be is that right we had the
director uh of the film rudy who also
directed hoosiers david onspa on the
program was that two summers ago now
2020 summer of 2020. i think so um and
he said that compared to
um
rudy
uh well i said compared to hoosiers
being made which he said was made up out
of whole cloth he called rudy a a ken
burns documentary compared to hoosiers
which kind of upset me but that's the
truth that's what he said
wait hoosiers is like that fake well
well it's based on this true story of
mile and high but everything else about
it all of it
is made up everything else all of it
jimmy chitwood the uh the picket
i'm heartbroken david
said angelo pizzo who wrote both films
as well
was sent he went to to the you know to
the to the small indiana town where it
happened
and reported back that there's no story
he goes they basically won nobody
thought it would happen there's no there
there about anything there's no drama
there's no nothing and so they made it
all up
all of it i know isn't that crazy oh my
god and that that you know the the scene
of gene hackman driving across the corn
field ah that's all fake that's
heartbreaking again before we get into
the football stuff too albert the one
last thing that really broke my heart
that david onsbach told us by the way
this is all on our youtube page
um he told us that the montage where
things actually get better for hickory
when they start winning and gene hackman
is on the bench laughing it up with um
with dennis hopper he said that they
kept that shot in there with them
laughing
uh even though that shot was was taken
when they were both getting ready to
actually be camera ready
and hackman turned to
hopper and thought the movie was so bad
saying
watch this this will be the end of our
careers and they and hopper laughed at
that line
and they kept that in the film and
that's part of the montage
i mean it's just a great story that's
fantastic that exactly is a really good
story it doesn't make up for it for for
them tooling me for 30 years into
thinking that the whole thing was real
but but that is a good story albert
perry here uh on the rich eisen show is
cliff kingsbury in trouble in arizona
based off of what we saw you know i i
it's you know the hard thing about it
rich is like i do think they've made a
lot of progress and i think you look at
where the roster was um and the position
they were in um you know with josh rosen
as a quarterback and having fired steve
wilks as the head coach
going into 19 i mean i i think you could
argue
um that place was as big a mess as any
place in football at that point and
i mean cliff has sort of re-energized it
and i think you know
developed a lot of good young players
there and gotten the most out of
veterans they brought in there some of
them you know are clearly on the back
end of their careers and built a good
staff and so there's so much positive
there but
you know just some of the things you
hear over the last
you know i'd say even like 12 hours um
you know like i i i think there's some
concern that there's going to be there's
going to need to be some level of change
now whether that happens on the staff or
with the head coach i don't know
um i think a key figure in all this too
that everybody should sort of pay
attention to
so we know you know michael bidwell and
and steve kahn the owner and gm
would be we would be
kind of part of this
adrian wilson um has a larger voice in
the organization for people who don't
know you know obviously he was a great
safety for all those years for the team
but he's risen up through the ranks of
the uh the organization now he's a vp in
the scouting department interview for
the giants gm job
um last week
and you know you just sort of hear like
that he
has a growing voice in the organization
and so
it'll be interesting to see
um how they come out of the next couple
of days i don't think cliff in any way
deserves to be fired he's brought the
team a long way and they've consistently
progressed even though they've fallen
apart at the end of every year they've
consistently made progress uh but just
sort of the rumblings you hear out of
there
are that there's going to be maybe some
level of change in the organization
based on how they finish the year look
as we all know breaking news only one
team
in the nfl finishes the season off a win
right so yeah um but the quite i don't
know how you bring about change of a
late season collapse
right and then you know i'm sure you've
seen it all over
twitter as well um the way that his
team's finished in college including
with mahomes like uh at quarterback so i
don't
how do you change whatever
that is
right if you're kingsbury or whomever
the hard part about it here so here's
the thing rich is like i think in
college
um and you know this as well as i do how
do college schedules set up
normally you're playing a bunch of
cupcakes early on right like let's call
it what it is like most power five teams
like if you've got four cupcakes on your
schedule they're probably among the
first six games right and so
like i think there's a reason why it
happened that way in college because
they aren't playing the university of
texas or oklahoma on september 1st you
know
and and then you look at why it's
happened in arizona
like is it because the roster's aging in
certain spots right because you know
like they've they've relied on some
older players and some key spots i mean
this has happened in new england the
last couple years too so i think there's
like an explanation for it
but the pattern certainly looks bad you
know and i think it's something that
you certainly have to look at you know
and that's the part of this that i think
is fair like do i think cliff could lose
his job no do i think that they
seriously need to see if there's a
deeper issue here just be hot be it
beyond maybe we rely on some older
players in some key spots and we can't
be doing that forever yeah i mean i
think it's fair to ask those questions
and so is that because the coaching
staff isn't adjusting to what's being
thrown at it um over the course of the
year is it because they're giving
answers to other teams and other teams
are using those answers in the back half
of the season i mean you and i both know
there's a challenging thing coaching in
the nfl and you have to constantly
evolve but i think that's only
accelerated you know like
where you know over the course of a year
it used to be year to year you had to
evolve now it's almost like over the
course of a season you have to evolve
and so i think asking those questions is
very very fair again do i think like
they need to blow things up um no i i
think it'd be tough to do that because
you've got a quarterback that's so
specific to the head coach that you
hired you know and kyle and cliff
um you know but i do think it's fair to
ask some of those big picture questions
based on how things have gone the last
three years and it's an excellent point
that you know in college you start with
cupcakes and it gets tougher as the
regular season in your conference moves
on it's just interesting that this year
michigan faced the cupcakes at the end
of their conference season so oh wow
well hey you know my your school goes
11-2 they throw parades my school goes
11-2 and half the coaching staff is
fired i guess the standards are
different different places you know
albert prayer everybody here on the rich
eyes and chill let's reset and move on
reset and move on as they say in the
radio business
so the fallout in dallas is going to be
what what's your estimation on that um
you know i i think like if if if you ask
jerry and stephen jones
but their their preference would be to
keep the staff in place completely well
dan quinn i mean dan quinn is the the
hottest candidate period i think i mean
i i think there if there's one in one a
i would go quinn and brian flores right
wouldn't you say that right now and
brian flores i think you throw like
nathaniel hackett's got some heat brian
dabal i think is starting to build some
momentum but yeah i mean i i think it's
fair to say that you know doug
peterson's got some too but i think it's
fair to say brian flores and dan coyne
will be at the top of the list and um
and look i think that's part of what it
is in dallas right now is
um you know would they like to keep mike
mccarthy and his full staff in place yes
is that feasible maybe not
and you know i think like whereas you
know at the beginning of the year i
think most of us you know to cover this
stuff and and talk to people you know
that'll talk people in that organization
would tell you
oh yeah maybe eventually they move on
from mike mccarthy to go to kellen moore
the more i've talked to people about it
over the last you know over the last
couple of months it sounds like that
maybe has changed too would they move on
from mike mccarthy to go to dan quinn um
that's how much they like him and the
job that he did and fixing their defense
and developing young players
like um you know like like like trayvon
diggs and parsons and michael parsons
and you know you look at it too rich and
it's i mean this becomes that because
like
you know i like he's got all this
interest i think he's probably the
favorite denver he's going to interview
with four of these teams he turned to 15
down
um and so you know i think jerry and
even have to have to ask themselves
these questions and it's not just
are we okay with mike mccarthy coming
out of this year it's are we okay with
mike mccarthy going forward if we lose
both kellen moore and dan quinn
and if we are in a position where we
might lose both of them
is there one of them that we would
rather have as our head coach mccarthy
and i think that that's i think that's
really the question they gotta ask and
um you know i i think quinn's done an
excellent job there and there's no
question i think you look at the job he
did in atlanta it's not like he was a
failure there either you know so i think
his second shot is coming i think
there's a good chance
you know where we're we're looking up
and and dan quinn's the head coach of
the broncos you know in a week
um you know but you know the question i
think becomes whether or not
uh that the cowboys really feel like
mike mccarthy is the guy going forward
to make the next defensive coordinator
hire to potentially make the next
offensive coordinator higher or
is it worth doing something to keep dan
quinn and they've been here before right
like say we're here with jason garrett
and wade phillips they gave uh jason
garrett a huge race here's the other
nuance that people i don't think are
paying much attention to they really
can't pay they really can't give dan
quinn a raise because he's still getting
paid by the falcons and so there are
offsets there so
jerry and stephen where they've thrown
money at this sort of problem in the
past
it isn't really going to work that way
here because of dan quinn's contractual
situation so to me it's just sort of a
fascinating spot for the jones family to
be in but i can tell you unequivocally
they love dan quinn they'd hate to lose
them and i think the question becomes
now how much would they hate to lose
well i mean can't they pay him more than
what the falcons were what the offset is
i mean can't they just go
but again i mean like why why do that uh
for what is quinn really going to say
all right i'll take that much more money
to stay here and be the dc and not get
back as an hc and all these other places
that are falling all over themselves for
me and then again you know steven jones
it seems like the jones have already
made this decision stephen jones went on
local metroplex radio yesterday and said
that uh you know the look we've seen
we've heard owners give votes of
confidence verbally before and you know
that that and a token will get you on
the old subway but so um i this has got
to be done now right like this this is a
developing situation as bill pedo used
to say on espn
and like i said i think that i i think
that the overwhelming likelihood the
likelihood is that stephen and jerry are
going to follow through on what they
said and and then mike mccarthy's back
as the head coach next year but i just
think that their their feelings for dan
quinn
i i think at least add a layer of
intrigue to this and you know again like
i've been told by multiple people how
the joneses have really kind of fallen
in love with quinn and the job that he
did and um you know i just think it's
fascinating because i do think
when we get to the end of this quinn
could have multiple offers to be head
coaches be to be a head coach in
different places and he's got a standing
relationship
with george payton the gm and denver in
fact
if they had ever decided to fire thomas
dimitrov and keep dan quinn in atlanta
george payton would have been the gm in
atlanta so there's a standing
relationship there i think quinn could
wind up getting again offered an offer
to somewhere else
and you know it sort of puts the cowboys
in one of these situations where it's
like
you know how much do you really like the
guy who's walking out the door my guess
would be they would stick with mccarthy
and just
sort of find a way to deal with it but
it but i i i don't think that it would
be the easiest thing in the world for
for for jerry or steven to watch dan
quinn walk out that door couple more
topics left for you albert breer in the
few minutes that we have left from
sports illustrated the denver situation
um you know um
isn't it dicey to take a job when
they're going to change owners and you
have no idea who the owner is coming in
i mean because
and you know you take a look at
belichick and what he tells his acolytes
and
and and whether or not it's a right job
to take you know he's the one who put
his name on a cocktail napkin retire
resigning as the hc of the nyj because
the owner changed and you know he signed
a contract saying i'll take the job
after parcells is done with it you know
when leon hess was the owner of the jets
woody johnson comes in and he's like i'm
out of here you know and so
what about that with the denver broncos
isn't that kind of dicey to take a gig
uh and then the owner changes you have
no idea
i believe bill belichick's line is the
owner's the one thing you can't change
right
yeah sure
yeah yeah uh yeah i mean i think it's i
think it's a fair question to ask you
know and um you know the hope is that a
lot of the people there would stay in
place you just hired george payton he's
incredibly confident um and he's done a
good job in his first year there joe
ellis the team president has been there
forever
um so you know i i think the hope for
most the people in the organization is
that you know like you would um you
would wind up
um you would wind up keeping the current
structure in place but
i'm with you there's definitely unknown
there and um yeah i don't know how much
has it been out there i'm sure it's been
out there somewhere but um you know i
know the trustees the bowling trustees
who aren't family members have a
fiduciary responsibility this is written
that the team goes to the highest
bidders so you want to talk about not
being able to control
where this is where this is going i mean
they don't have any control you know
like you don't know who the highest
bidder is going to be it could be
somebody
i mean like from out of the market that
you know no one has any had any clue
about you know before the process
started and so
um yeah i mean i i'm with you rich like
that is a very serious question i'm sure
it's one that's being addressed in every
one of these interviews and um you know
george payton's handling the interviews
but you know that's why joe ellis has
been available to the guys who are
interviewing so
absolutely you know and i think you know
then the question becomes with with
quinn is his relationship with george
payton such where the two want to work
together and have wanted to work
together for a while
and you know it's sort of at that point
where it's like well we have to take
this risk because we've always wanted to
do it together the other thing is and i
would say this too that team's in pretty
good shape i mean if you look at where
they are and yeah they don't have
quarterbacks figured out right yet just
yet yeah but you know i know people in
that organization
feel like they are where they were in
2012 before they got peyton manning in
that there's a set up there with young
talent at receiver a young pass rusher
young coroner
that looks a lot like the setup in 2012
that attracted peyton manning out of
denver well the last one for you then
albert is yesterday you know an
interesting monday mike mayak my friend
and long-time nfl network colleague is
fired as the general manager
for the raiders at the same time uh my
alma mater jim harbaugh announces the
the hiring of a defensive line coach
from notre dame mike elston who's a
former michigan football player but he
welcomes him back and the press release
is talking about it's one big happy
family and
so
you know
mayox firing is a deck clearing
so what what's going on with the raider
situation and harbaugh still a
possibility here what do you think i
don't know that it's specifically being
done for harbaugh i mean one thing that
i that i heard
going back a couple months is that you
know the business side people and
they've cleaned out their business side
over the last six months the business
side people in vegas
you know kind of viewed um after you
know gordon was fired is this a
chance to like reimagine um the
organization you know and i think
if mike had stayed on it would be a sign
that rick versace was in really good
shape and i i always felt like if they
decided to fire mike
it was in order to take big swings to
allow whoever the next coach is to maybe
recreate the organization in his own
image and so you know i've talked for a
couple months about the idea that they
could be a team that could pull off a
coach trade and maybe they call
pittsburgh about mike tomlin maybe they
call new orleans about sean payton not
seeing those guys ago but it's you know
i mean it's worth asking right and then
harbaugh's the other one
um and you know there's obviously a
relationship between mark davis and jim
harbaugh almost hired him in 2015 when
michigan got him um and harbaugh coached
there in 2002 and 2003.
um you know that said i do think that
defensive line higher
i mean i'll tell you it got my attention
rich because somebody had pointed this
out to me you want to go back to the
iowa state michigan thing here we can
how you know there was a two-week period
there where ryan day was very
aggressively filling out his staff it
was pointed out to me that you know jim
harbaugh had two or three staff openings
that he was doing nothing about and he
was just leaving those jobs open and
that was an indication maybe that he was
on his way out well the fact that they
went and hired a d-line coach to me
at least signals that
michigan feels like they're in a good
spot and harbaugh's okay with the idea
of going back and maybe there's at least
some framework for a contract to get
done and i'd warn anybody you know don't
climb in jim harbaugh's head it's a
crazy place and and and i would not like
guess what he's going to do right now
um because if you go back to 2015 you'll
remember this rich there was a time when
people were saying there's no way he's
going back to college and he did you
know so i think it's not over till it's
over but i would say that defensive line
hires at least a good sign that jim
harbaugh is you know potentially coming
back to michigan for i think this would
be an eighth year right
and um and you know i i i also think you
know at the same time simultaneously
that
um the raiders are looking to take a big
swing
to to fill that head coaching spot
i think the the interest in harbaugh's
one side of it and i think the firing of
mayo is probably another sign of there
albert greatly appreciate always thanks
for the time
much all right thanks have a good one
you got it that's albert breer i follow
him on twitter at albert brewer you
should as well hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here